he works for them this is unbelievable
islamofascist telling the president of
the united states what to do with
americans stuck in kabul and he's like
well because it's all
part of the plan
it's the most humiliating garbage i've
ever seen from an american president
we've seen some pretty humiliating
garbage from the american president
joe biden has now resisted pleas from
our allies to extend the withdrawal
deadline of august 31st now remember it
was joe biden who originally set that
deadline of august 31st joe biden came
in he said august 31st is the day that
we are going to get out and then we can
celebrate the end of the afghanistan war
by september 11th and then the taliban
took him up on that and they said okay
well if you mean august 31st then august
31st it shall be and now the taliban is
refusing to move off of that date
despite the fact that they've taken over
kabul and are apparently obstructing
efforts to get people out of kabul so
the european allies the g7
they met with joe biden yesterday and
apparently they were telling him we need
you to give us more time right we have
people on the ground there we need
american troops on the ground beyond
august 31st so we can get our people out
and joe biden said no he said that
staying brings quote added risk to our
troops with increasing threats from isis
well you know what would have been
really nice at this point if you think
about it what would have been awesome is
if let's say we had you know a skeleton
crew like 2 500 troops with bagram air
base under our control and let's say
that we had an afghan national army
capable of beating back the taliban
because they had close air support from
the united states as well as civilian
contractors on the ground holding the
major cities in afghanistan so that we
could work on evacuating people if they
wanted to get out and let's say that we
had had that like um you know three
months ago
oh yes indeed we did and then joe biden
decided you know it'd be a great idea
what if we just take out all the
soldiers and leave everything else
behind and then shockingly we now have
to put soldiers back in to get everybody
else out and now we're going to do this
a second time we're going to
precipitously withdraw our military
in the middle of an evacuation effort
now joe biden says that the evacuation
effort right the precipitous withdrawal
of the military
it makes no difference says joe biden
it's not a big deal because the people
that we're getting out they're really
not helping with the evacuation yet it's
not it's not that big a deal here is the
problem it is a rather large deal we are
already removing people from on the
ground right now and no matter how many
times joe biden says well you know we
can still remove here's if we're out by
august 31st we have to start
removing american soldiers from the
ground in kabul today right and we have
we've started removing american soldiers
from the ground in kabul
as people are attempting to get to the
airport
now that's all fun and games
until it comes time for the mass
evacuations to happen and we need more
people on the ground
all of this really all of this springs
from a peculiar ideological failing of
joe biden when it comes to the american
military joe biden believes that leaving
americans behind in kabul
is less important than getting american
soldiers out of kabul
that is the basic calculation that is
going on right now he believes that
americans will just forget about what's
going on in kabul
but if americans are left behind which
undoubtedly there will be particularly
outside of kabul because we're right now
we're just talking about the americans
who are in kabul there's still
presumably hundreds or thousands of
americans who are outside of kabul still
in afghanistan who may want to get out
we have no way of getting them out now
his belief is that if he can just brazen
this out for a couple more weeks if he
can just brazen this out to the point
where the vast majority of americans are
out of country the media will turn from
yelling at him to praising him for
ending the war in afghanistan americans
will forget about everything bad that is
happening in afghanistan and it just
won't be on the front pages anymore and
everything will go back to normal except
until we have credit for ending the
afghanistan war that is joe biden's main
calculation americans won't care about
the midterm or long-term strategic
consequences of pulling out of
afghanistan already that's been pushed
into the background
the acute crisis on the ground in kabul
has made people already forget and
really not care very much about the fact
that china is sweeping in that russia is
very eager for the united states to
leave afghanistan that iran is very
eager about all of this that the united
states just lost its air bases not just
in afghanistan but also in pakistan
right now the american people like are
not even thinking about that stuff right
now they're just thinking about the
acute crisis so biden's belief is if we
can just get past this acute crisis if
we mostly solve the acute crisis most
people will leave us alone and my
approval ratings will start to go back
up again he's now down to 41
in the approval ratings
what he can't have however in his own
political calculation is a tax on
american troops by isis
which is again a very bizarre
calculation because american soldiers
are there to repel attacks from
terrorists to protect american citizens
joe biden's logic however is if we have
to leave american citizens there to
prevent attacks from isis on american
troops we will do that that is the
precise reverse of what the american
military exists to do the american
military exists to break things and kill
people in defense of americans joe
biden's belief is that americans should
continue to be in danger american
civilians should continue to be in
danger so we can protect american troops
that's not the way any of this works
civilians are not there to protect the
military the military is there to
protect civilians and if you ask anyone
serving in the military they agree with
this
this is not an anti-military point this
is a definitional point
if you ask anyone in the military what
is your job they would say my job is to
protect americans
joe biden believes that apparently the
americans were stuck on the ground in
kabul are less important than getting
the troops out because isis might attack
the american troops at kabul airport
again that is only happening as a direct
result of joe biden withdrawing
what military we had from afghanistan in
the first place and also destroying the
afghan military from the inside remember
the entire afghan military had been
built along the lines of working with
the american military in terms of being
able to call in close air support and
use both the american air force as well
as the nation to afghan air force which
required american upkeep joe biden
withdrew all of that and so the forces
just dissolved
trobiden's original plan as of july was
that the u.s would leave the afghan
national army would would would probably
hold for another few months and then it
would probably collapse and then you
would say well it was going to happen
anyway but it didn't happen that way as
soon as the u.s withdrew the entire
thing collapsed and now you've got
americans trapped and joe biden's
highest priority is not getting the
americans who are on the ground in kabul
out it is getting the soldiers out
because he's afraid
for two reasons one if there's an attack
on american troops the american troops
are gonna have to fire back and then
we're gonna have to put real troop
numbers back on the ground in kabul and
the war that he was so eager about
withdrawing from will have now been
heightened to its greatest point since
and will have no foothold in the country
right so that is his great fears that we
get drawn back into the war because he's
such a and because he created this
situation himself that is fear number
one is there will be attack on american
troops
the the second fear that he has is that
the protraction of the conflict will
lead to political consequences so one is
the conflict itself and one is the
timeline of the conflict he's hoping
this whole thing is over by september
11th and then he can go back to watching
matlock and spooning cream of wheat into
his addled mouth right that that is his
that is his greatest and most ardent
desire and all they have to do to get
there is just keep lying to you and keep
fibbing to you and keep hoping that you
stop paying attention and instead you
pay attention to their budget deals and
instead you pay attention to covid it's
wag the everything else in order to
distract from what's going on in
afghanistan
and again the baseline for success is
now set so low in afghanistan that if we
get out the majority of the americans
who are on the ground joe biden is going
to call it a success
if we get out the vast majority of the
americans who are on the ground we have
a few behind but we get everybody else
out he's going to call that a success
and say well it was always going to go
this way he's already saying this like
right now they're already calling it a
huge success and saying it was already
going to go this way even though it was
not destined to go this way this is a
joe biden decision pure and simple and
even though it is certainly not a huge
success the whole point for example of
the evacuation of dunkirk was to
preserve the british army to fight the
nazis afterward
it is not called a success when you
retreat in the face of a eighth century
goat-hurting barbarian army
for no reason other than your own vanity
which is what joe biden did right here
so here's the latest from the new york
times president biden said tuesday the
u.s intended to withdraw completely from
afghanistan at the end of the month as
planned rebuffing pleas from britain
france and other nato allies to keep
troops in kabul and hastening the end of
a frantic evacuation that has become a
grim coda to two decades of war again
even the way the new york times phrases
this a grim coda to two decades of war
the united states had lost zero troops
in combat since february of 2020
the main american effort in the war
ended in 2014.
all media coverage was directed toward
the idea that it was a it was a bare
bones necessity for the united states to
get out of afghanistan completely
that is not true and by polling data by
the way the polls suggest that americans
want it out of afghanistan but if you
said to americans should we leave like a
skeleton force in there in a non-combat
facility to advise the afghan military
most americans are like okay because we
do that everywhere we have american
troops all over the world we have
american troops in probably over 100
countries at this point
even as mr biden spoke from the white
house officials said the united states
had already begun to reduce its military
presence at hamid karzai international
airport in kabul
sending about 300 of the 5800 marines
and soldiers home in anticipation of the
conclusion of their rescue mission
within a week
the sooner we can finish the better said
the president hours after informing
world leaders of his intentions during
an emergency virtual meeting citing the
threat from isis k which is like special
k except with islamic terrorists and
operating in afghanistan he said every
day we're on the ground is another day
we know that isis k is seeking to target
the airport attack both u.s and allied
forces and innocent civilians yeah it
would be great if we had like a military
presence that could kill those bastards
wouldn't it hmm
yeah i wonder where that went
biden didn't close the door to extending
what has become an immense evacuation
effort he said he has contingency plans
but um i i don't trust him on that
because he said this was all planned in
the first place remember it was all part
of the plan joe biden has now taken on
the full heath ledger in the dark knight
perspective of the joker which is nobody
panics if you have a plan okay well
there's no plan
you're just saying there's a plan and we
all know this we all know this
so the troop drawdown has begun
according to stars and stripes
the the president stuck to his deadline
on tuesday
his decision came as the taliban warned
it would not accept a deadline extension
that's the real reason it's not because
joe biden thinks we're going to be done
by august 31st he knows we're not going
to be done by august 31st you can't find
a single person in an intelligence or a
defense position who believes that
everyone who needs to be evacuated will
be evacuated by august 31st they do not
exist
okay this is across the aisle there is
bipartisan agreement
across the aisle but this will not be
done by august 31st what is the real
reason that august 31st is the date
because the taliban again a bunch of
barbarian goat herders from the eighth
century
are telling joe biden the president of
the most powerful military force in the
history of the world what to do
that is how craven and pathetic and
buffoonish this president is when it
comes to foreign policy
i mean that's unbelievable the taliban
the taliban are saying you guys better
leave by august 31st now the normal
american response be or what
or what
we have overwhelming air power we're the
most powerful military on planet earth
and if you touch us we will
we will
bomb you forward into the stone age
if you if you touch us we still you have
no air force we will still go in and we
will kill so many of you it will make
your head swim and then you can talk all
you want about how you took over the
country you have a lot of bodies to bury
so you're gonna let us do what we need
to do or we're not leaving
right we could do that but joe biden is
so scared of the bad headline of having
to actually bomb the taliban his new
peace partners that he is now running pr
for the taliban he is now enthralled to
the taliban he is bowing before the
taliban he works for them this is
unbelievable
a bunch of theocratic
fascistic islamofascists telling the
president of the united states what to
do
with americans stuck in kabul and he's
like well
all right
it's the most humiliating garbage i've
ever seen from an american president
we've seen some pretty humiliating
garbage from the american president
ranging from
the president having interns on their
knees in the oval office to january 6.
we've seen some pretty bad stuff from
american presidents in the course of my
lifetime let me just say that this makes
all of this looking nothing like nothing
the president of the united states
playing pr spokesperson for the taliban
remember this is the group
that housed the people who committed
september 11th killing three thousand
american citizens refused to turn over
osama bin laden
these are the exact same people okay it
is not a different group
omar's son is on the taliban ruling
council the head of the haqqani network
which is an al-qaeda offshoot is on the
taliban council and currently running
security in kabul
the co-founder of the taliban with mala
omar is now back in power it's the exact
same human beings and joe biden is not
just taking their their statements under
advisement he's just listening to them
so how many americans are still left
over there apparently the the pentagon
finally announced how many americans
were out now you'll remember as of last
week it was like 2200 americans were out
and we kept saying over and over members
of the press say how many americans are
out how many americans are out people
kept asking because the biden
administration was just giving overall
evacuation figures right they were
loading a lot of afghans onto planes and
then they were saying it's thirty
thousand forty thousand fifty thousand
seventy thousand
and americans are saying okay right but
how many of those are americans because
we've been told there are 10 to 15 000
americans on the ground in kabul alone
forget about the rest of the country
yesterday
the pentagon said that there were some 4
000 american passport holders and their
families who had been evacuated
so if you just do the math you're still
talking about what less than a third of
the americans in kabul who have been
evacuated at this point
how's this for a title ben shapiro show
subscriber destroys like button with
clicks and logic i'd watch that make it
happen gang